we sent Ronnie out to LA for some bits
over the summer it's so great Ronnie
accused Gary of big timing him so I
guess so we went out to dinner one night
right so we're at a restaurant but
probably about 10 of us at the table
we're sitting outside a reality star a
guy who's on the show selling sunset
walk by and Ronnie goes
I'm a big fan of his so the guy and his
girlfriend they're holding hands and
they went into the restaurant so Ronnie
goes I'm gonna go in and say hello to
him and I go oh stop it now you're full
of [ __ ] Gary go ahead can I just finish
it so I go Ronnie you know what why
don't you let the guy like don't chase
him like he'll come out and when he
comes out we can say hello I'll even
introduce you but like like let him be
don't chase him so the guy came out and
he's walking by and I said hey this is
uh Ronnie from the Howard Stern Show
he's a big fan and uh the guy kind of
you know pressed by him quickly I will
take Ronnie's side in this one why do
you need to introduce Ronnie I mean I
was trying to help I was trying to help
we're trying to help me he was going to
go chase this guy down Howard it was
going to be really weird
facing him oh [ __ ] dude all I was
gonna do I was gonna walk inside say
big fan
uh he he has a a car that he had built
by a custom place that I watched the TV
show and I was just going to say man it
was a really beautiful car and I just
wanted to tell you and and walk away do
you feel with Ronnie you have to parent
him like he could [ __ ] up in any minute
is it that is that what's going on no
but it was it was like it was like
Ronnie got super excited and the guy was
holding his girlfriend's hand I don't
know when they went in a restaurant I
didn't see anybody waiting and then Gary
and I didn't I could have done something
hold on hold on can I just say something
Ronnie you I am not to walk out with his
girlfriend and embarrass him Ronnie who
is this guy and why do you like him so
much what show is it it's selling Sunset
it's like this real estate show with a
bunch of hot chicks it's on Netflix this
guy Jason oppenheim he owns this big
real estate company is it your feeling
that Gary treats you like all right let
me handle this Ronnie because you'll
embarrass the show or something that's
that's how it looked because it was
worse what he did because the guy now he
comes out of the restaurant
where there's a table of like 15 people
and he go Gary stands up and he goes hey
Jason it's Ronnie from The how it starts
to say hi I was at the other end of the
table when this was going on so I didn't
know what I didn't know this was
happening and all of a sudden this guy
walks behind the table and Gary like
leans up a little hey hey I'm like what
the hell is going on over here I've seen
Gary JD I've seen Gary do that move to
Bradley Cooper and uh you know I got
news for you I would probably prefer
Ronnie just walk up to the guy himself
and say hey and Ronnie wasn't even going
to say Howard Stern he was just going to
say hey full disclosure I was actually
thinking of the Bradley Cooper thing and
thinking of like when I annoyed Bradley
Cooper and I thought I don't know if
Howard would appreciate somebody being
chased down like that so I figured I
wasn't chasing him well Ronnie I
apologize but I can tell I can tell this
really got her to run his skin I thought
it was one of those things like okay it
was a moment but I found out that Jason
and some other guys from the show made
it out to Vegas to go see a concert they
visited Ronnie and they told me they
walked in Ronnie's house it was like the
first thing [ __ ] Gary [ __ ] Gary so
oh it wasn't the first thing John what
did Ronnie say was he uh upset with Gary
yeah he was pissed at Gary because Gary
kind of scared that dude away Gary was
like hey it's Ronnie from The the Howard
Stern Show you got to talk to him and
you know Ronnie could have handled it on
his own I think Ronnie should have just
gone to talk to him he idolizes the guy
and loves him so much you know I love
Gary dearly but he does read the
situation wrong sometimes like why did
there need to be an announcement excuse
me everybody ding ding ding on my glass
excuse me excuse me um
you know what else Gary did I saw the
elf puppet on Hollywood them and Vine
and he said hey alphabet alphabet
running the limo driver over here from
the Howard stard Show come on well there
you go all right A Little Adventures out
in L.A between Gary and Ron
[Music]
[ __ ] everybody